hey 42 here throughout history people
have tried
weird and wonderful ways to stay healthy
the aussies said that sitting inside a
dead whale carcass
could cure rheumatism the ancient
egyptians used alligator dung
as a contraceptive yes really the
victorians encourage people to eat tape
worm eggs
to aid weight loss the romans whitens
their teeth
with urine morning breath is bad enough
never mind piss breath yet as long as
there's been
physical illness there's also been
mental illness
and as long as there's been mental
illness there's been a variety of
highly disturbing so-called treatments
that make harold shipment seem about as
deadly as a damp flannel
in the 1800s the field of psychology
began to emerge
and the idea that the brain should be
treated differently than the body
psychology soon diverged into three main
schools of thought
phrenology psychophysics and moral
therapy
phrenology is a since discredited field
which
basically involves studying lumps and
bumps on the skull
to try and predict a person's
personality or character traits
scientists figured that the brain was
like a muscle and
therefore parts that were exercised more
would grow more and so bumps were a sign
of well-developed brain
tissue based on that logic jay leno
should be the smartest man alive
phrenologists would map the skull into
different sections
each responsible for a different
attribute for example a bit above the
ear could tell you
how self-destructive a person was and
the very top of the crown was linked
with confidence levels
in fact the phrase you should get your
head examined
comes directly from this practice the
problem was
scientists still had a pretty poor
understanding of what parts of the brain
control the different aspects of our
behavior and so the therapy was
dismissed by the mid-1800s
i mean just look at this phrenological
mental map it looks like a paint by
numbers
of gwyneth paltrow's [ __ ] marketing
terminology
then there was psychophysics which
wanted to explore the link between the
physical world
and mental experiences for example how
does light
make something bright or how does sound
make something loud
wilhelm wundt who has the most german
name since volkswagen
is nicknamed the father of psychology
by those who aren't so fond of freud and
incest
vundt was a pioneer in this field he
would collect data by recording patients
responses to different stimuli
showing them different colors for
example vundt and his contemporaries
assumed that if you could control the
conditions in a laboratory
then you could control a patient's
reactions
the problem is experiences are
subjective
for example it's presumed not everyone
sees colors as the same hue
your red could be my blue and then
take music beethoven's name fills me
with wonder and serenity
but it turns alex de large into a
quivering
feeble fetus so in the end psychophysics
taught us a lot about how we experience
things
but it didn't really tell us anything
about why people experience things
differently
lastly the victorians practiced moral
therapy
the belief that people with mental
disorders could be cured by offerings of
compassion
kindness and dignity various religious
groups including the quakers
argued that the asylum system needed to
be reformed
so it was more sympathetic towards
patients who should not be seen as
raving animals and
chained up as was typical but vulnerable
human beings
part of reforming the system involved
redesigning the buildings in which
patients were housed
this is the period where all those
asylum hospitals you see in the movies
like
one flew over the cuckoo's nest and
shutter island were built
imagine grand buildings with gardens
where patients could get some fresh air
in america dr thomas story kirkbride
advocated the use of architecture as
part of the cure
and not just a prison in which to hold
the afflicted
so he designed a blueprint for the
perfect asylum
one that would enable patients to be
classified by type of illness
but also enable easy surveillance with
ample sunlight and ventilation
between 1845 and 1910
73 kirkbride plan hospitals were built
and many still exist today now
moral therapy advocated that these
institutions
needed to offer a safe space for
vulnerable people
and should only be used as a short-term
solution
but in reality budget constraints
overcrowding
poorly trained staff and dubious
psychiatric knowledge
resulted in a very different system
indeed
most asylums functioned as glorified
prisons
a place to keep individuals with mental
illnesses
away from their families and communities
because they were seen as a threat
the problem was anyone who exhibited
slightly
abnormal behavior was deemed a lunatic
and as anyone who's ever endured reality
television will tell you
the term normal is rather subjective
leaving the system wide open to abuse
for example many inmates were simply
political prisoners
people who'd expressed radical views and
so were conveniently dismissed as mad
and locked up women were particularly
vulnerable to misdiagnosis and were
institutionalized much more frequently
than men
at the time a woman's assets
automatically passed to her husband upon
death or incarceration
and so lunatic asylums offered a nifty
way to get rid of an unwanted spouse
and make a quick bit of cash on the side
the law
also stated that any man in charge of a
woman
so a father husband or brother could
have a woman detained against her will
and many women who did speak out against
female oppression
were deemed as hysterical and dangerous
by those closest to them
in 1887 a pioneering journalist
nellie bly heard about the mistreatment
of female inmates at an asylum in new
york
and decided to go undercover by acting
insane to have herself committed
to find out if those rumors were true
the following
year bly would recreate phillis fogg's
fictional trip around the world
in a record-breaking 72 days
so it's fair to say she was prepared to
go the distance
in the asylum she discovered conditions
more cruel and
inhumane than she could have ever
imagined
patients were forced to consume spoiled
food and contaminated water
they were tied together and forced to
pull carts around like
mules sometimes they were made to sit on
hard wooden benches for up to 12 hours a
day
and if they moved or made a noise they'd
be beaten
throughout the night she heard constant
screams horroring
down the long empty curry doors
one woman repeatedly begged for her own
death
whilst another bellowed murder over and
over again
bly also witnessed one of the nurses
beating a patient with a broom handle
for crying
then they tied her up covered her face
with her sheet
and bound it tightly around her neck to
subdue her screams
and placed her in a bathtub filled with
ice cold water
nurses and orderlies then held her in
the tub until she gave up struggling
and lost consciousness what bly had
witnessed was known as hydrotherapy
a common treatment for patients
experiencing manic episodes
doctors believed the shock of cold water
would help to reset patient systems
people were sometimes submerged in a
bath for hours at a time
mummified in cold wet sheets or
handcuffed to a shower and sprayed with
icy water
the victorians were so convinced about
the benefits of hydrotherapy
they invented all sorts of strange
contraptions
to give the consumer a good soaking at
home
like this rocking bathtub which was
basically your very own wave machine
or the buffer surprise which could dunk
you into ice water
at any moment and probably explains why
most people don't like surprises
what shocked nellie bly the most was the
fact that most of the patients she met
were not suffering from mental illness
before they arrived at the asylum
but many had since experienced grave
psychological trauma
because of these horrific treatments
fortunately bly's report did lead to an
investigation
and improved conditions but this barely
scratched the surface of what was going
on behind closed
doors harriet martino a british writer
who's known as the first female
sociologist
wrote how in asylums we see chains and
straight waistcoats
three or four half-naked creatures
thrust into a chamber filled with straw
to exasperate each other with their
clamour and attempts at violence
or else gibbering in idleness or moping
in solitude
which to be fair doesn't sound like a
fun saturday night when you think
of insane asylums you might think of
padded rooms and straightjackets
but actually the victorians were much
more creative
and crueler than that they used manacles
harnesses coffins coercion chairs
and crib beds to confine and subdue
patients
some institutions forced patients to
wear hannibal lecter style muzzles
but rather than fava beans and a nice
chianti
they got freezing baths and a neck
collar
unsurprisingly a very high number of
people
died in asylums in 1829 william
scrivenger
a patient at lincoln asylum was found
dead from strangulation
after being strapped to his bed in a
straitjacket
and left overnight without supervision
doctors conducting the postmortems
discovered
a worrying trend in asylum deaths
patients kept dying with broken bones
and broken ribs in particular to shed
light on this
many former patients wrote letters to
authorities about the abuses taking
place
such as orderly subduing patients by
kneeling on them
until they gave up eventually an
investigation in 1887 resulted in a new
legal precedent
that asylum patients who died with
broken ribs
should be treated as a manslaughter case
subsequently orderlies were
taught to restrain patients more
humanely
now given that people could be sectioned
for just about
anything and everything asylums became
overcrowded very quickly
so mental health professionals if you
can call them that
were under increasing pressure to come
up with ways to cure patients
quickly to have them dismissed and thus
free up room for their next unfortunate
souls
this led to a lot of trial and error
which
was well mostly error
one of the most downright bizarre was
rotational therapy
which posited that subjecting someone to
excessive centrifugal force
should cure their crazies patients were
spun round and round at high speeds in a
circular motion
normally in a swinging chair until they
eventually calmed down
and promised to obey the doctors at
which point they'd be released
and allowed time to sleep and recover as
well as probably
vomit and change their trousers the
pioneer of this
so-called treatment was none other than
erasmus darwin
charles darwin's grandfather erasmus
darwin was a physician
philosopher and scientist but
unfortunately
he wasn't particularly good at any of
those and so wasn't taken very seriously
by most
probably because he liked to record his
ideas in bad poetic verse
like some lovesick teenager but it also
didn't help that his ideas included such
gems as excessive spinning to ease brain
congestion
and yeah nobody paid much attention to
darwin's crazy idea at first
but then an american doctor benjamin
rush came along
he thought spinning the ever-loving [ __ ]
as of mentally ill people
sounded like a marvellous idea now the
aptly named benjamin rush claimed that
rotational therapy had a calming effect
on his patients
hmm yeah well let's face it if you strap
anyone into a spinning tea cup for long
enough
they'll probably pass out and calm down
eventually
if the ice baths and human salad spinner
didn't cure the old noggin
then victorian physicians usually
resorted to chemicals
these were administered in the form of
tonics a mixture of powerful and
addictive substances that would make the
fda cry themselves to sleep
such as morphine lithium salts cocaine
and chloroform furthermore patients who
were admitted with syphilis
which was rampant at the turn of the
20th century were injected with malaria
without their knowledge or consent
because
it was supposed by austrian doctor
julius wagner jurek
that malaria would kill syphilis within
the bloodstream
to be fair it did work to a certain
extent in reducing syphilis
the issue was about 15 of patients
then died from malaria now why does that
not surprise me
i would love to say that mental health
treatments improved after the victorian
era
but i'm afraid it was quite the opposite
electric
shock therapy was widely practiced in
the early to mid 20th century
and in 1935 antonio edgasmones
invented the lobotomy for which he was
awarded the nobel prize in medicine
but all it did was turn people into
human vegetables
by 1951 20 000 lobotomies had been
carried out in the u.s
and other countries did their fair share
as well
funnily enough it was the ussr who were
first to outlaw lobotomies in 1950
because it was in their words contrary
to the principles of humanity
because you know the soviet union was
famously pro-humanitarian
europe and eventually the rest of the
world followed in subsequent years
and i think you'll all join me in saying
thank goodness for that but just to be
safe
next time you visit your psychologist
and he offers you an iced
tea just take care and watch what he's
doing with that ice pick
thanks for watching you can now buy my
new book sticker flag in it on amazon
or get the audio book on audible you'll
find a link to both in the description
below
thank you